NEW SABER RATTLING TONIGHT FROM
DICTATOR NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR
KIM JONG-UN.
HE NOW SAYS HE HAS INVINCIBLE
MILITARY.
CNN'S BRIAN TODD HAS DETAILS,
AND SHOWS A DISTURBING BACKDROP
OF WEAPONS.
>> WOLF, THEY SAY THEY'VE NEVER
SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS FROM
THE REGIME.
KING JOHN IS DEPLOYING A NEW
ARSENAL OF WEAPONS SOME, OF
THEM WHICH ARE HARDER TO DEFEND
AGAINST 4 IN THE NORTH AT
KOREAN ADVERSARY.
>> MOST AMBITIOUS WEAPONS, A
BACKDROP FOR KIM JONG-UN TO
MARK THE ANNIVERSARY OF THE 7TH
THE WORKERS PARTY.
THE DICTATOR DECLARING HE NEEDS
THESE WEAPONS TO DEFEND HIS
COUNTRY AGAINST THE HOSTILE
U.S., WHICH HE SAYS IS CAUSING
INSTABILITY ON THE KOREAN
COMMITMENTS TO.
BUT IT'S WEAPONS AND THE WAY
WAS PRESENTED WHICH HAS
ANALYSTS CONCERN TONIGHT.
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING
LIKE THIS BEFORE, AND INDEED
WHEN HE PUT ALL HIS MISSILES
TOGETHER, IT LOOKED LIKE THE
SMITHSONIAN.
>> THEY CAME UP WITH A SHOWROOM
ALMOST LIKE A CAR SALESMAN
SHOWING WHAT'S ON THE LOT.
WHAT'S ON A LOT IS A LOT OF
LETHAL POWER.
>> INCLUDING WITH NORTH KOREA
SAYS IT'S A HYPERSONIC MISSILE
WITH A DETACHABLE GLIDER
WARHEAD.
FIRST TESTED LAST MONTH.
A WEAPON THAT EXPERTS SAY IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO SHOOT DOWN.
A NEW CRUISE MISSILE WHICH
FLIES LOW TO THE GROUND, FIRST
TESTED LAST MONTH.
ALSO ON DISPLAY, WHAT ANALYSTS
BELIEVE IS THE WALLS ON 16, ONE
OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
INTERCONTINENTAL BALLISTIC
MISSILES, POSSIBLY CAPABLE OF
CARRYING MULTIPLE WARHEADS,
SHOWN IT RECENT PARADES BUT NOT
BELIEVED TO BE TESTED YET.
KIM ALSO RECENTLY TESTED
MISSILES LAUNCHED FROM TRAINS.
WHICH CAN POP OUT OF A TUNNEL
HIDEAWAY AT A MOMENTS NOTICE.
>> KIM JONG-UN IS TELLING THE
WORLD AND SPECIFICALLY THE
UNITED STATES THAT IT HAS A
FEARSOME ARSENAL OF MISSILES.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
INTIMIDATION WHICH THEY HAVE
TAKEN TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
THEY ARE GETTING BETTER AND
BETTER AT THIS.
>> ANOTHER IMPORTANT MESSAGE
ANALYSTS BELIEVE KIM IS SENDING
WITH THIS SHOW OF FORCE.
>> NO RETREAT FOR NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THE MESSAGE IS, WE ARE
DANGEROUS BUT WE ARE NOT GIVING
UP ON NUCLEAR WEAPONS, AND DEAL
WITH IT.
>> SHOWCASED AT THIS LOCAL
LATEST EVENT, SOLDIERS
PERFORMED HIGHFLYING MARTIAL
ARTS KICKS CRASHING LOCKS.
A SOLDIER CRASHED THROUGH A
BLOCK WITH HIS HEAD.
AND A BARE-CHESTED SOLDIER
FOUGHT OFF ALL COMERS ALL TO
THE DELIGHT OF KIM AND HIS
SISTER.
AT SEVERAL RECENT EVENTS, KIM'S
APPEARED RECENTLY SLIMMER THE
NEEDED MONTHS AGO, AND THIS
TIME HE WAS FILMED WEARING
POLISH SANDALS WITH HIS SUIT.
>> HE'S LOST WEIGHT, WE DON'T
KNOW WHY, HE APPEARS TO HAVE
GOUT, HE HAS A GOUT.
HE IS NOT A HEALTHY PERSON.
IF YOU ARE KIM JOHN'S DOCTOR,
BEFORE YOU TELL HIM TO HIT THE
GYM OR STOP EATING HIS FAVORITE
DESSERTS, YOU PROBABLY THINK
THIS IS PERSONAL HAD HIS UNCLE
ASSASSINATED, AND IS
ASSASSINATED MANY OF HIS
GENERALS AND POLITICAL
FOLLOWERS, SO I DON'T THINK
HE'S GETTING A VERY STRICT
REGIMEN FROM HIS DOCTORS.
>> NORTH KOREA ALSO PAYS CLOSE
ATTENTION TO KIM'S PHYSICAL
ATTENTION FOR GOOD REASON.
AS ONE PERSON PUT IT, AS SCARY
AS THOSE MISSILES ARE, I WOU